we saw venom and there were a whole
bunch of Easter eggs you might have
missed so we're gonna actually hang on
let me make sure my symbiote is ready
all set here kale okay let's do this
several elements of venom were inspired
by the 1993 six issue comic book series
venom lethal protector written by David
McKee Lanie
this was the storyline that basically
saw venom transitioned from being a
straight-up villain to more of an
antihero just like his arc in the film
when he goes from wanting to kill all
humans to just devouring the really evil
ones he's growing lethal protector also
featured the life foundation the evil
corporation that's doing evil symbiote
experiments on the homeless in the movie
in the comics they're not a big company
but an underground paranoid survivalist
society dedicated to building doomsday
proof communities for its members to
live in after an apocalypse their leader
in the comics still Carlton Drake lethal
protector also featured journalist Eddie
Brock moving from New York to San
Francisco and it introduced a bunch of
new offspring of the original Venom
symbiote including the evil riot in the
movie he's the symbiote who bonds with
Carlton Drake and fights with venom
during the big action climax another
David Nicolini story the five issue
Planet of the symbiotes arc also played
a part in inspiring venom it's all about
a group of alien symbiote it's plotting
to take over the earth just like those
pesky troublemakers get up to in the
movie man if you can't trust parasitic
goo from outer space who can you trust
am i right
speaking of mister mikolai me he an
artist Todd McFarlane are credited with
creating the character of venom and
appropriately they get a little shout
out in the movie we see briefly that
Eddie's ex-girlfriend Anne works for the
law firm of Nicolini and MacFarlane
Anne's transformation late in the film
into a female version of venom is also
based on Marvel or the so called she
venom character first appeared in 1995
and the first human to transform into
the monster was in fact and weighing an
venom after his breakup with Anne
he lives in an apartment complex known
as the Schuler building this too has a
secret meaning in 1982 a Marvel fan
named Randy Schuler rode into the
company suggesting that Peter Parker
should get an all-new all-black
super-powered spider suit designed by
the Fantastic Four's Reed Richards
Marvel's then editor-in-chief sent Randy
220 dollars for the idea and the chance
to write a script about the suit but the
story never came together and was not
published Randy still credited with
helping to come up with the venom
character and thus he earns a place in
the new movie even some of the dialogue
in venom comes straight out of Marvel
Comics the human devouring aliens
memorable line about snacking on a thugs
eyes was originally featured in the
amazing spider-man number 374 and was
directed at Peter Parker himself so many
snacks so little time also does this
mean that Eddie Brock is partially
eating people too
like if he has indigestion after the
scene is it because you know what never
mind at one point
Eddie text with an old friend named
Barney Bushkin this too has significance
for Marvel super fans bush ken was
Brock's editor at The Daily Globe in New
York and in the comics he's a longtime
rival of Jay jonah Jameson and also
mentions that Eddie ran into trouble at
the globe which prematurely ended his
journalism career in the comics he
misidentified a criminal known as the
Sin Eater whose real identity was later
revealed by Peter Parker ruining his
reputation
this in turn inspires Eddie's hatred of
Peter Parker making him a more
attractive host for the Venom symbiote
see it's all coming together and of
course there's the granddaddy of venom
Marvel Easter eggs the post-credits
sequence which reveals a red-haired
woody harrelson as serial killer Cletus
Kasady aka carnage here's hoping they
get to make venom 2 or that's gonna be
extra weird on re-watch Plus Stan Lee
shows up late in the game and somehow
knows about the Venom symbiote inside
Eddi without being told cuz he's Stanley
how do you think he knows about better
hit us up in the comments and let us
know also remind us if there is cool
venom lore that we forgot about oh and
did we see enough of his tongue I feel
like maybe we need to see more of his
tongue yeah okay bye
[Applause]